herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie der frühling steht vor der
tür und damit auch die schönste zeit um
sich zu verlieben
da macht man vielleicht nicht daran
denken dass die liebe auch enden kann ja
sogar in vielen fällen enden wird
glauben wir meinem heutigen gast ist die
liebe sogar gefördert hat denn je
ich begrüße sehr herzlich eva illouz
hier in berlin
sie ist eine der bekanntesten soziologin
in unserer zeit professorin an der
hebräischen universität von jerusalem
und der ss in paris und sie studiert
seit 20 jahren unsere liebesverhältnisse
herzlich willkommen frau - sie haben
dieses buch geschrieben als letztes buch
warum liebe endet muss denn jede liebe
zwangsläufigen aufgestaut natürlich
nicht es gibt viele liebesbeziehungen
die nicht enden
aber es passiert immer häufiger
trennungen gehören inzwischen zu unserem
leben
daher stellt sich die frage warum unter
anderem weil die menschen anders als
früher ihre sexualität heute zunehmend
erkunden
[Musik]
außerdem ist die sexualität zum glück
legitimer geworden die menschen können
mehr partner haben und gehen daher
zwangsläufig verschiedene beziehungen
ein
das sieht die große liebe finden oder
eben nicht probieren sie eine ganze
reihe von beziehungen aus wenn ich über
das ende der liebe spreche meine ich
damit natürlich nicht dass jede
liebesbeziehung zum scheitern verurteilt
ist
ich sage einzig dass unser lebensstil
dazu führt dass wir von einer beziehung
zur nächsten wechseln
unseren lebensverhältnisse sich geändert
haben darüber werden wir ganz viel
sprechen heute beginnen wir vielleicht
noch einmal damit wie eigentlich
überhaupt diese liebesverhältnisse sich
verändert haben im verhältnis zu den
trennungsgerüchten sie tragen sie ja
schön auf dass es früher das ökonomische
modell war dass die partner zusammen
gehalten hat tauscht liebe gegen geld
quasi der mann hat nur in einer festen
beziehung sexualität erleben können die
frau wiederum braucht einen festen
partner um ökonomisch überhaupt
gesichert zu sein
heute hingegen gibt es die romantische
liebe und in der romantischen liebe sind
wir frei zu gehen ist das ein
fortschritt auf kurze die so natürlich
ist es ein fortschritt
das heißt aber nicht dass die dinge
damit leichter werden
bruder wir automatisch glücklicher wären
in früheren traditionellen
gesellschaften waren scheidungen viel
schwieriger und es gab keine
wahlmöglichkeit weder für männer noch
für frauen aber vor allem nicht für
frauen mit der möglichkeit einen partner
zu wählen hat auch die möglichkeit
zugenommen ihn wieder abzuwählen
also eine beziehung wenn man möchte
wieder zu beenden
den preis für die größere auswahl ist
das unser partner und abwählen kann oder
wir ihn abwählen
das ist ein fortschritt wenn man an die
individuelle freiheit und an die
unabhängigkeit glaubt sowie an die
relative autonomie der individuen
gegenüber der gemeinschaft der religion
und der gesellschaft aber wie gesagt die
dinge werden durch den fortschritt nicht
einfacher
und er macht uns nicht glücklicher wir
machen fortschritte und sind weniger
glücklich
das müssen wir verstehen und das heißt
auch dass mehr autonomie mehr
selbstbestimmung nicht zwangsläufig
glücklich machen
ja genau das meine ich
viele leute bringen das durcheinander
deshalb kritisieren konservative bürger
immer wieder die heutige gesellschaft
oder liberale normen oder die freiheit
weil auch sie beobachten dass uns die
größere freiheit nicht glücklicher macht
aber ich denke wir mussten uns
entscheiden ob wir freier oder
glücklicher sein wollten
und diese entscheidung haben wir
kollektiv getroffen
wir haben beschlossen freier zu sein
obwohl wir dadurch weniger glücklich
sind oder besser gesagt es uns weniger
gut geht
ich glaube nicht dass wir als individuum
gut gerüstet sind um allein außerhalb
von starken gemeinschaften zu leben aber
ich finde viele gemeinschaften haben
sich nicht bewährt
oft unterdrücken sie frauen und
akzeptieren menschen nicht die der
gemeinschaft nicht angehören
der preis den wir für die freiheit
bezahlen ist eine anspruchsvollere moral
das heißt mehr gleichberechtigung von
mann und frau und mehr
gleichberechtigung zwischen denjenigen
die zu einer gemeinschaft gehören und
jenen die nicht dazugehören
wenn sie sagen dass mehr freiheit nicht
wirklich glücklich macht und wir uns
trotzdem auf gesellschaft für die
freiheit entscheiden warum tun wir das
denn ist es nicht eher rational rational
ich weiß nicht wie sie rationalität
definieren individueller sicht ist es
eindeutig rationaler mehr autonomie zu
haben
also zb als frau über den eigenen körper
bestimmen zu können fragt man frauen ob
sie es vorziehen
die kontrolle über ihren körper den
männern zu überlassen wie es bis in die
19 60er und 70er jahren üblich war
oder ob sie lieber wie in der heutigen
zeit autonom und frei über ihren körper
bestimmen
obwohl sie dadurch in kauf nehmen müssen
ein weniger gesichertes leben als
ehefrau und mutter zu haben
mir scheint dass die meisten frauen
lieber autonome sind und allein über
ihren körper bestimmen
ich glaube wir können es uns nicht
einmal vorstellen in die verhältnisse
vor den 1960 er jahren zurückzukehren
als frauen für die eröffnung eines
bankkontos noch die erlaubnis ihres
ehemannes brauchten
ich denke kollektiv können wir nicht
zurückgehen
daher beantwortet sich diese frage von
selbst es ist eine vollkommen rationale
entscheidung insofern also nichts
anderes möchten als das was wir heute
haben ich würde gerne mit ihnen ein
bisschen über diese trennung und
sprechen wie trennungen auch von statten
gehen und etwas was ich in ihrem buch
gelernt habe ist dass die trennungen
meistens von frauen ausgehen
warum ist das so das ergaben umfragen
der 19 80er und 90er jahre
ich weiß nicht ob es immer noch zutrifft
ich denke heute beenden auch vermehrt
männer beziehungen mehr als früher
das da vor mir die frauen trennungen
initiiert haben damit zu tun dass sie
immer mehr in den arbeitsmarkt
einsteigen und dadurch wirtschaftliche
alternativen und möglichkeiten bekamen
außerdem werden frauen und männer anders
sozialisiert
frauen werden dazu erzogen für andere zu
sorgen und ihre gefühle auszudrücken
daher erwarten sie dass auch von den
männern
diese hingegen werden dazu erzogen im
kapitalistischen markt system
konkurrenzfähig zu sein und ihre gefühle
nicht zu zeigen
daher fehlt es ihnen viel schwerer die
forderungen der anders sozialisierten
frauen zu erfüllen
ich vermute dass dies bei den frauen
frustrationen auslöst überdies herrscht
immer noch ungleichheit in den privaten
haushalten meistens leisten die frauen
doppelte arbeit
sie haben einen job und übernehmen auch
den haushalt weil die männer ihren
anteil nicht leisten
daher werden eher die frauen unzufrieden
sie sagen auch dass es eigentlich nie so
verschiedene normative der trennung gibt
die immer wieder fast schon archetypisch
auftauchen sie ihnen drei solche
verschiedenen typen von von narrativen
der trennung die offenbarung die
anhäufung und das trauma für die die
gerne kurz mit ihnen anschauen weil ich
das interessant finde und zwar
insbesondere die offenbarung sie
zitieren aus der autobiografie von
virgin russell den berühmten philosophen
der schreibt oder beschreibt wie eine
radtour macht und auf der rolandstraße
vor sich hin abend schreibt er dann dass
er ganz plötzlich gemerkt hat dass er
seine frau nicht mehr liebt und zitieren
ihn
er sagt ich hatte bis zu diesem
augenblick nicht die leiseste ahnung
gehabt dass meine liebe zu ihr
nachgelassen hatte zu der frau und er
verlässt sie dann auch da denkt man doch
irgendwie das ist schräg nun was er
schreibt entspricht nicht zwingen den
tatsachen
auf diese weise erzählt er sich selber
wie er aufgehört hat sie zu lieben
möglich hat sie ihnen im lauf der zeit
in vielen nicht sichtbaren dingen
enttäuscht was er sich aber nicht
eingestehen will dieser tatsache wird er
sich an einem gewissen punkt bewusst und
er beschließt sich einzugestehen dass er
sie nicht mehr links
damit will ich sagen dass es nicht nur
verschiedene formen von trennungs
prozessen sondern auch verschiedene
erzählformen gibt es sind also
verschiedene prozesse und ebenso
verschiedene geschichten die sich
menschen erzählen sind wir sozusagen bei
den geschichten und eine solche
geschichte wäre eben diese offenbarung
dass man das gefühl hat oder es sich im
nachhinein erzählt ist vielmehr wie
schuppen von den augen der teppich genau
das ist die offenbarung
die umkehrung des sich verlieben sowie
gewisse leute sich auf den ersten blick
in eine person verlieben und wissen dass
sie für diese bestimmt sind ist dieses
narrativ der offenbarung die umkehrung
des sich verlieben
man gesteht sich plötzlich ein dass man
diesen menschen nicht mehr liebt es gibt
auch andere arten zu erklären warum man
aufgehört hat jemanden zu lieben
man könnte sich eingestehen ich wurde so
oft von dieser person enttäuscht und
frustriert dass es an einem gewissen
punkt zu viel wurde
es ist das bild des fasses das zum
überlaufen gebracht wurde
es gibt noch ein anderes narrativ das
narrativ des traumas wenn ihr partner
etwas tut dass sie so sehr schockiert
dass sie nie vollständig darüber
hinwegkommen
sie können es ihm nie wirklich verzeihen
und dadurch vertrauen sie ihm nie mehr
richtig
ich nenne das narrativ des traumas denn
es ist wie ein massiver vertrauensbruch
in der beziehung zweier menschen
wenn es dann zur trennung kommt erklärt
man sich diese vorkommnisse als vorboten
von dem was dann geschieht
doch das sind nachträgliche erklärungen
wir sind nicht sicher ob es die
wirklichen gründe für das scheitern sind
es ist ja meistens im leben oder dass
wir uns wochen im nachhinein irgendwie
zurecht legen gerade die brüche im leben
versuchen wir oft mit einer eigenen
geschichte uns dann so zu erzählen dass
es für uns eben die auch sinn macht weil
ja nicht kopflos durchs leben gehen
wollen sondern um selber irgendwie auch
verstehen in dem was wir tun
das tun wir tatsächlich aber in meinem
buch warum liebe endet versuchte ich auf
zu zeigen dass wir uns einerseits dinge
im nachhinein zurechtlegen
andererseits gibt es objektive kräfte
die dazu führen dass sich heutzutage
mehr paare tränen als früher
es geht also nicht nur darum was für
geschichten wir uns erzählen sondern
auch darum zu verstehen warum die
gesellschaft in der wir leben kräfte
entwickelt die stärker sind als unser
wunsch zu lieben und geliebt zu werden
und diese für uns unsichtbaren kräften
untergraben die beziehungen die wir
entwickeln möchten
in modernen gesellschaften würden viele
unsichtbare kräfte die es den paaren
äußerst schwer machen zusammen zu
bleiben
das versuchte ich in diesem buch zu
dokumentieren
damit sind wir ja eigentlich beim
begriff der negativen beziehung das ist
so ein kern begriff dieses buches und
was daran für mich interessant war ist
unter anderem dass sie sehr genau zeigen
dass das problem der negativen beziehung
eigentlich gar nicht so sehr ist dass es
zu einer trennung kommt sondern dass die
negative beziehung eigentlich gar nicht
richtig beginnt wir sind gar nicht mehr
wirklich fähig sagen sie uns aufeinander
einzulassen das heißt es gibt auch keine
auch keinen grund sich dann auch zu
trennen weil es beginnt garni kann sie
mal ein bisschen erklären was das genau
ist so eine negative beziehung
der begriff negativ hat eine lange
geschichte in der philosophie darauf
möchte ich jetzt nicht eingehen
einfach gesagt beziehe ich mich auf zwei
konzepte aus der phänomenologischen
tradition dass eine stammt von jean paul
sartre der unterbewusstsein als
unbestimmt versteht das heißt in
gewisser weise haben wir keine konkreten
eigenschaften das selbst bleibt
unbestimmt deshalb ist es frei
tatsächlich bedeutet diese
unbestimmtheit dass wir nicht wirklich
wissen was wir wollen
weil wir gar nicht wissen wer wir sind
und genau das ist die voraussetzung für
freiheit
diese voraussetzung ist einerseits sehr
gut verursacht aber auch angst
die zweite traditionen ebenfalls aus der
phänomenologie ist leicht anders und
stammt von martin heidegger negativ ist
was geschieht wenn das was man
normalerweise tut zusammenbricht wenn
etwas zusammenbricht ist man gezwungen
plötzlich darauf zu achten was man tut
obschon es für ein paar sekunden noch
fällige routine war und man sich dabei
nichts gedacht hat für martin heidegger
ist das ein kreativer moment eine
eruption die dinge zusammenbrechen lässt
und uns dadurch zwingend sie zu beachten
das meine ich mit negativ diesen
zusammenbruch wie wir wissen können
beziehungen jeden moment zusammenbrechen
ob wir in ihnen drin stecken oder sie
noch gar nicht begonnen haben
dies zwingt uns sie zu beachten genau
das tut die klinische psychologie sie
zwingt uns die ständig lauernde gefahr
zu sehen nämlich dass unsere beziehung
scheitern könnte oder bereits zerbrochen
ist
und wir versuchen zu verstehen warum das
passiert ist
diese zwei bedeutungen von negativ
benutze ich in meinem buch und wie sie
richtig bemerkt haben lautet einer
meiner wichtigsten befunde dass die
gleichen kräfte die es unser schweren
beziehungen einzugehen
auch aktiv sind wenn langjährige
beziehungen zerbrechen
ziel des buches ist aufzuzeigen dass in
beiden situationen die gleichen kräfte
am werk sind
diese negativität der beziehungen die
eben nichts damit zu tun habe dass die
beziehungen schlecht wären oder so etwas
sondern dass sie so unglaublich brüchig
auch geworden sind sie nehmen da ja auch
nennen auch einige beispiele sie sagen
zum beispiel one-night-stands
seitensprünge freundschaft plus cybersex
das sind alles auch beispiele von
solchen negativen beziehungen
die sind auch begünstigt durch den
kapitalismus das ist auch eine these des
buches wie genau hängen die beiden
zusammen
ein zusammenhang geht auf die zeit nach
den 19 60er jahren zurück als die
sexualität frei wurde
dadurch wurden männer und frauen ein
wenig gleichberechtigter frauen konnten
ihre sexualität mehr genießen als zuvor
als sie mit charme und sünde behaftet
war
doch vor allem begann die visuelle
medien industrie also kinowerbung und
das fernsehen den sexualisierten körper
von männern und frauen aber insbesondere
von frauen
einzusetzen und zu verwerten hat man bis
zu den 1970 er jahren selten sex szenen
zu gesicht bekommen stieg bereits in den
1970 er jahren aber vor allem in den 19
80ern die zahl der sexszenen massiv
sexualität und sexualisierte körper
wurden immer mehr bestandteil von werbe
spots von kino- und fernsehfilmen weil
zuschauer davon angezogen werden
so wurde die sexualität zu einer neuen
ware die vom kapitalismus massiv
ausgebeutet wurde weg und zwar von der
visuellen medien industrie welche die
sexualisierten körper von frauen
gewinnbringend einsetzt
die sexualisierung der beziehungen hat
zahlreiche auswirkungen auf die
möglichkeiten emotionale bindungen
einzugehen
das ist eines der themen mit denen ich
mich im buch befassen
dieses zusammenspiel von gefühlswelten
und markt beziehungen das ist ja etwas
was sie schon sehr sehr lange
beschäftigt sie haben eigentlich ein
großprojekt dazu angelegt seit 20 jahren
schon beschäftigt sie auch dieses
verhältnis zb der konsum der romantik
das war die situation schon damals hat
sie das interessiert
romantik und kapitalismus warenwelt und
liebes welt wie gehören die beiden
zusammen die finden sie zueinander und
wie korrigieren sie sich auch und dann
das buch warum liebe weh tut jetzt warum
liebe endet es geht immer wieder um
dieses verhältnis was bringt sie auch
soziologen dazu sich so sehr auf diese
liebes welt in kombination mit dem
kapitalismus zu fokussieren
ich würde es so sagen die modernität die
natur der moderne also was es heißt
modern zu sein
eine kapitalistische wirtschaft zu haben
und in einer gesellschaft zu leben in
der die individuen allein außerhalb von
gemeinschaften reden
das sind wichtige fragen in der
soziologie und da die liebe traditionell
vor allem mit weiblichen ängsten
assoziiert wird und die soziologie von
männern dominiert wird gehört die liebe
weniger zu ihren themen
daher ist eines der ziele meiner wie sie
zurecht sagten langjährigen studien
aufzuzeigen dass ein thema oder gefühl
das universell persönlich und
individuell zu sein scheint von
kollektiven veränderungen und vor allem
vom kapitalismus geprägt ist die welt
der gefühle und die welt der wirtschaft
stehen also aus traditioneller sicht im
gegensatz zueinander
aber ich denke die sicht hängt mir mit
dem zusammen was wir aufgrund unserer
ideologie glauben möchten und weniger
mit empirisch belegten fakten
so haben sich zum beispiel frauen und
männer bei der partnerwahl immer
finanzielle überlegungen gemacht und das
tun sie auch heute noch ob sie es
zugeben oder nicht status oder bildung
sind dinge die eine wichtige rolle
spielen wenn wir uns verlieben wenn wir
die menschen begegnen mit dem wir leben
möchten
das ist interessant
die frage für mich war wenn die familie
nicht mehr für die partnerschafts
vermittlung und die heirat zuständig ist
und wenn die familie auch nicht mehr der
ort ist an dem menschen wirtschaftlich
gesehen ihr bedeutendstes
betätigungsfeld haben weil sie außer
haus in einem kapitalistischen markt
system arbeiten
was passiert dann mit den romantischen
gefühlen und vor allem was passiert mit
den romantischen gefühlen wenn die
romantische liebe das hauptthema der
großen verbrauchermärkte wird die es
seit beginn des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
gibt
sie haben dafür auch den schönen begriff
der morde tief geprägt stadt commodities
stadtgüter ermottis also mit emotionen
aufgeladene güter oder waren die wir
kaufen können
und sie zeigen immer wieder sehr schön
auch dass man uns zwar weismachen will
dass wir gefühle liebe zuwendung kaufen
könnten
aber eigentlich ist es immer nur dass
die warenwelt die wir uns wirklich gegen
geld kaufen können
die frage ist ja schlussendlich auch
können wir uns eigentlich auch
vielleicht sexualität kaufen
möglicherweise aber können die uns
eigentlich auch einen partner kaufen
können wir uns auch zweisamkeit kaufen
diejenigen die an sex roboter arbeiten
einen zum teil tatsächlich ja das können
wir hier in barcelona arbeitet dr
santos an einem sex roboter früher war
er erfolgreich als forscher tätig heute
nutzt er sein wissen um silikon puppen
eine art leben einzuhauchen
mein ausgangspunkt war ein
computermodell das emotionen und gefühle
simulieren kann
das habe ich selbst entwickelt dann habe
ich ein humanoider system gesucht und
sind das sexpuppen industrie gefunden
im moment bin ich dabei die einzelnen
bausteine die sexpuppe und das emotions
modell zusammenzuführen und so bringt er
seinen sex roboter in fahrt es ist unser
leben zu genießen
auf sexy wenn ich zum beispiel ihre hand
berühren kann ich dieses gefühl für
immer haben
wenn meine frau mich verlassen würde
wäre ich mit ihr zusammen
ich mache keine witze sie gibt mit die
gesellschaft die ich brauche hsg st
gallen ethik professor thomas beschorner
ist überzeugt dass digitalisierung und
robotik wichtige themen sind die vor der
sexualität nicht halt machen
umfragen zeigen dass sex mit robotern
mehr als nur ein fetischist bin ziemlich
sicher dass die besitzer solcher geräte
ihren puppen sehr schnell namen geben
werden sie werden sicherlich gekleidet
wer noch hübsch gekleidet werden man
wird mit ihnen reden man wird vielleicht
mit ihnen sogar irgendwann sonntags auf
der couch sitzen und mit ihnen tatort
gucken wenn man das weiter wenn man
freundin ist wahrscheinlich nicht aber
ich weiß nicht ob es darum geht ob es
eine gute oder eine schlechte idee ist
es fragt sich viel mehr ob roboter aus
unserem leben wegzudenken sind oder
nicht und ich denke sie lassen sich
nicht mehr wegdenken
wir bewegen uns auf eine gesellschaft zu
in der roboter eine immer stärkere
emotionale rolle in unserem leben
spielen
nehmen sie das haustier
natürlich sind haustiere lebewesen aber
keine wesen die sich mit uns unterhalten
trotzdem vermenschlichen wir unsere
haustiere
aber auch wenn wir die haustiere die wir
lieben vermenschlichen ist uns bewusst
dass unser haustier nicht das gleiche
ist wie ein mensch der uns antwortet
anschreit oder umarmt sie sich nun vor
wir können eine genügend komplexe
software entwickeln die bis zu einem
hohen grad das menschliche gehirn und
eine große vielfalt an gefühls
reaktionen auf unser handeln limitiert
da gibt es keinen grund warum wir diese
hybriden wesen nicht irgendwo zwischen
lebewesen und objekten einordnen sollten
ähnlich wie haustiere die für uns etwas
zwischen menschen und tieren darstellen
das versteht man unter post humanismus
darum geht es wenn wir mit maschinen
zusammenleben wir interagieren mehr und
mehr mit hybriden wesen
es gibt feministinnen die sagen ein
problem um den sex robotern ist
klarerweise dass die gestaltet werden
nach einem weiblichkeit ideal das
eigentlich sexistische und das in
bordellen mit solchen sexpuppen
beispielsweise auch praktiken ausgeübt
werden die frauenverachtend sein und das
eigentlich dann ein frauenbild
kultiviert wird was problematisch ist
man könnte sagen dass die tatsache warum
mehr roboter weiblich sind mit sehr
spezifischen männlichen sexfantasien
zusammenhängt das wiederum scheint damit
zusammenzuhängen
dass frauen in gewissem sinn in der
gesellschaft objektiviert werden und ist
daher für viele männer kein großer
unterschied ist zu ausgeklügelten
robotern überzugehen
ist aktuell in what was the different
giulio caccini recorder frauen bereits
objektiviert sind und als objekte
behandelt werden ist das sehr
wahrscheinlich
aber ich vermute aus markttechnischen
gründen werden solche roboter bald auch
für frauen hergestellt und es werden
männliche wie weibliche roboter verkauft
sie habe am anfang auf meine frage ob
das eine gute idee ist oder nicht gesagt
das ist gar nicht die frage sondern die
frage ist vielmehr ist das vermeidbar
oder nicht ich finde das interessant die
sind natürlich soziologin sie wollen in
erster linie beschreiben und nicht
bewerten aber wenn wir uns zum beispiel
überlegen oder studien anschauen die
welt ist ja insgesamt sehr von der
sexualität durchdrungen es gibt die
porno fiction sagt mama der ganzen welt
das ist auch ein thema was sie eben
beschäftigt die wahren industrie die
sexualisiert wird und gleichzeitig haben
die menschen weniger sex als früher
am ausgeprägtesten ist das in japan wo
40 prozent der menschen zwischen 20 und
30 jahre angegeben sie hätten überhaupt
noch gar nie in ihrem leben sex gehabt
mit einer realen person aber natürlich
mit sex roboter und natürlich
konsumieren sie mangas und pornos haben
sie dann auch wie vor nicht den eindruck
dass vielleicht etwas daran
bedauernswert oder stufen sein könnte
sie haben recht ich denke
wissenschaftler sollten es vermeiden die
probanden ihrer studien zu bewerten
zumindest wenn sie verstehen wollen
warum diese tun was sie tun und welche
gründe sie dafür verantwortlich machen
[Musik]
als wissenschaftlerin ziehe ich es zb
vor zu ergründen warum eine person trump
welt anstatt sie deswegen zu verurteilen
wenn wir etwas in der wissenschaft
reichen und in der gesellschaft bewirken
wollen müssen wir zuerst einmal
verstehen was menschen tun
das heißt nicht dass ich wenn ich
hoffentlich besser verstehen wie es um
die wirte und praktiken in der
gesellschaft bestellt ist mir nicht auch
ein urteil erlaube was zb die
politisierung der gesellschaft betrifft
wird unter feministinnen intensiv
diskutiert ob das etwas gutes oder
schlechtes ist
viele sechs befürworten die
feministinnen finden dass kolleginnen
welche die sexualisierung des weiblichen
körpers unterbinden möchte eine form von
puritanismus vertreten
diesbezüglich bezieht stellung und zwar
unabhängig davon ob ich finde 46 sei gut
oder schlecht
diese frage stelle ich gar nicht denn es
ist nicht meine aufgabe sie zu
beantworten
aber ich stelle fest dass die sexualität
von der kapitalistischen industrie
vereinnahmt worden ist und dass der
weibliche körper von der medienindustrie
massiv ausgebeutet wird
die kriterien für diese ausbeutung
stammen fast immer von männern
tragischerweise kann man folgendes
beobachten während die frauen meinen sie
hätten sich selber befreit unterwerfen
sie sich dem männlichen blick und der
kontrolle der männer in der
medienindustrie
industries das ist der eine punkt der
ist sehr interessant und dann gibt es ja
noch einmal den zweiten
auf den würde ich gern noch einmal
zurückkommen warum genau haben den
menschen mehr 6er weniger sechs warum
genau gibt es diese tendenz es gibt zum
beispiel artikel von 2018 aus dem
atlantik des ex recession ist er
überschrieben worden also die sechs
rezession
es gibt auch einen artikel in der
zeitung die alle aufzeigen das
sexualverhalten vor allem auch unter
jungen menschen das bezieht sich immer
mehr eben auf die pornoindustrie auf
vielleicht irgendwelche hologramme oder
so etwas aber in den sozialen medien
auch sucht man sich entsprechende
angebote aber nicht reale körper nicht
reale begegnungen so die äußerst
interessante studie die vom atlantik
magasin letzten dezember oder januar
veröffentlicht wurde fand tatsächlich
heraus dass die jüngeren menschen etwas
weniger sex haben als die leicht älteren
die in den 90er jahren geboren wurden
einen der gründe wenn nicht sogar den
hauptgrund sehe ich in der tat sache und
das ist das thema meines buches dass es
viel schwieriger ist die regeln für das
entstehen von beziehungen zu erkennen
am meisten wird sex in stabilen
beziehungen praktiziert obwohl
gelegenheit sex immer beliebter wird
analysiert man die sexuellen aktivitäten
im gesamten leben von menschen haben
männer und frauen am meisten sex in
stabilen partnerschaften
wenn es aber immer schwieriger wird
stabile beziehungen einzugehen haben
menschen noch weniger sex weil
beziehungen für die meisten der gewohnte
rahmen dafür sind dadurch konnten wir in
einem interessanten paradox in einer
kultur die körper und begegnungen hyper
sexualisiert wird weniger sex
praktiziert wie kommt denn diese kultur
erschwert es beziehungen einzugehen und
aufrechtzuerhalten was verunsichern
wirkt diese unsicherheit ist ein
beherrschendes element moderner
beziehungen wir worden
sie haben einen sehr interessanten punkt
der mich beschäftigt hat sie sagen
nämlich im grunde genommen hat die
romantische liebe ist möglich gemacht
den partner frei zu wählen und ihn auch
aus eine einzigartige person zu wählen
währenddessen jetzt eigentlich die
technologie das umgekehrte mit uns
anstellt nämlich jeder wird vergleichbar
und austauschbar und damit geht
eigentlich seine einzigartigkeit
verloren nun die traditionelle
romantische liebe gründet praktisch per
definition darauf jemanden als
einzigartige person zu wählen wenn sie
nun in einer gesellschaft leben in der
sie mit relativ wenigen menschen in
kontakt kommen ist es relativ leicht
diese eine person zu erkennen aber die
internet technologie verändert die
begegnungsmöglichkeiten grundlegend denn
aus einer situation der knappheit
geraten wir nicht in einen überfluss
sondern in einen hyper überfluss deshalb
hat die dating-plattform kinder die
regel eingeführt dass man nach 106 zwölf
stunden lang gesperrt wird
man kann also nur 100 stellen sie sich
das mal vor bewusst können wir so viele
informationen gar nicht aufnehmen
unser gehirn ist nicht gerüstet für eine
so große auswahl an möglichen frauen und
männern die ähnlich attraktiv und
interessant sind die viel herumgereist
sind und sich uns vor den ägyptischen
pyramiden oder einer schönen insel
zeigen die vielen objekte werden wir uns
ununterscheidbar
lassen sie uns doch ganz kurz anschauen
wer genau kinder nutzt und aus welchen
gründen kinder ist eines der sozialen
netzwerke das eben kontakte vermittelt
seit dem jahr 2012 dagegen den start
hatte es nach eigenen angaben acht
milliarden kontakte gemanagt
schauen wir ganz kurz die menschen mit
kindern umgehen und leben heute
vertrauen millionen ihr herz stehen
algorithmen an
viele erhoffen dass ich hab schon hat
und mit dem besten ruf unter par als
mileys und was man gern macht und so
funktioniert's nachricht sagt ja nach
links
[Musik]
mögen sich beide ein match
schwäbe male und los ging's mit chatten
man hat das gefühl es gar nicht anders
geht das nur über plattformen und über
meine bis sechs jahre lang behandelt ja
mal ein lied für jeden über keine
kleinen und domäne dass ich es denn aber
ich finde es immer schwieriger fall vor
allem mammut werk sie also leidet vor
allem kommen nur mit beth ist also so
hübsch dass die elefanten schießen
natürlich und sympathisch die auch
harrison ford bei kinder sei das risiko
einer abfuhr kleiner
wie schnell neue beziehung kommen wir
schnell wissen was man isst man will
ich bitte gott sich narren mit optimus
pad aus früheren
es muss also sagt ja alles man kann
alles erleben was man nun möchte man
kann sich das ja selbst gestalten und es
ist das coole daran weil man ist ja
weder zeitlich noch örtlich gebunden
durch cent und ich finde das super vier
super cool weil es einen viel freiraum
gibt einfach wie man wann und wo man es
benutzen möchte und mit wem
und ja ich habe ich tolle erfahrungen
damit gemacht die haben gute erfahrungen
damit gemacht was sagen sie dazu
finde die leute machen gute und
schlechte erfahrungen mit kindern oder
auch gar keine
viele sagen auch sie würden endlos
weiten chatten und sich mit jemandem
verabreden
aber am schluss dann doch niemanden
wirklich treffen
[Musik]
oder sie sagen man müsse 200-mal zweiten
um 2 ticks zu haben für einige
funktioniert es für andere nicht
es ist daher sehr schwer zu sagen ob es
wirklich etwas bringt wenn wir kinder
und ähnliche apps nach den resultaten
bewerten wissen wir nicht wie sie
funktionieren und warum sie so abhängig
machen was sie aber sicher vermitteln
ist hoffnungslos
ich würde also sagen die ware die sie
verkaufen ist hoffnung auch wenn sie
zwei jahre lang keinen erfolg hatten
bringt die hoffnung sie dazu
weiterzumachen
[Musik]
darüber hinaus wird dating zum spiel
umfunktioniert so waren die konzept
verantwortlichen ursprünglich für kinder
als spielplattform und als soziales
netzwerke social network plattform sie
verwandte sind also das dayton in etwas
viel diffus und amorphis in eine
plattform auf der man andere menschen
trifft eine art soziales netzwerk bildet
und spielt dadurch verändert sich der
zugang zur romantischen liebe
vollständig die eine frau die wir vorhin
gehört haben findet das total cool weil
sie dadurch ihre freiheit erkunden kann
ich bin mit ihr einverstanden genau das
ermöglicht einem diese plattform
sie lässt dich freiheit verspüren aber
oft ist es eine freiheit die dich mit
leeren händen dastehen lässt
[Musik]
wenn sie sagen die währung sozusagen ist
ist hoffen oder das ziel ist hoffnung
worauf hoffen denn die menschen
er hob sie hoffen der liebe ihres lebens
zu begegnen dieser einen person die
anders ist in diesem meer von
möglichkeiten die social of possibility
aber das ist ja interessant also
einerseits haben sich unsere
lebensverhältnisse so verändert dass es
mehrheitlich negative beziehungen gibt
also beziehungen die gar nicht richtig
anfangen diese sehr sehr vielen sehr
flüchtigen beziehungen die auf einem
großen hedonismus beruhen es geht in
erster linie darum selber boss zu
kriegen was man sich erhofft und gar
nicht mehr so sehr sich auf seinen
gegenüber einzulassen und trotzdem
hoffen wir auf die große einzige one and
only bliebe in unserer kultur gibt es
verschiedene tendenzen moderne kulturen
sind höchst widersprüchlich diese
widersprüchlichkeit definiert was es
heißt ein moderner mensch zu sein
wir streben stabilität und sicherheit
gleichzeitig wollen wir abwechslung
freiheit und autonomie
diese beiden gegensätze treiben uns und
auch die wirtschaft an
es ist das bestreben diese widersprüche
zu vereinen der romantischen liebe ist
also nicht aus der modernen kultur
verschwunden
im gegenteil noch nie war unsere
gesellschaft so besessen davon das paar
ersetzt gemeinschaft und familie
wenn heutzutage menschen erwachsen
werden
setzt man sie einer sehr kompetitiven
und unsicheren gesellschaft mit einer
höchst unsicheren zukunft aus zudem ist
es für einzelpersonen schwieriger
geworden wirtschaftlich über die runden
zu kommen
[Musik]
es gibt also sehr viele gute
psychologische emotionale und
wirtschaftliche gründe aus der
paarbeziehung die einheit zu machen in
der menschen leben wollen vor allem um
eine stabile emotionale basis für
anerkennung und wertschätzung zu haben
doch gleichzeitig gibt es viele kräfte
die dieses ideal der großen wahren liebe
untergraben
deshalb suchen die psychologen auf und
konsumieren ratgeber oder pornografie
all diese spannungen und widersprüche
führen zu einem enormen konnten dass das
individuum das moderne individuum
speziell von dieser zerrissenheit
geprägt ist also das moderne individuum
ist eines das einerseits eben diese
selbstbestimmung sucht und gleichzeitig
diese zugehörigkeit war denn das
individuum davor auch zerrissen aber in
anderer weise oder war es weniger
zerrissen
wahrscheinlich war es weniger zerrissen
der deutsche soziologe max weber
definiert die moderne folgendermaßen
alle bereiche des soziallebens die
wirtschaft das rechtssystem die familie
die religion sind immer mehr voneinander
getrennt das wären sie zuvor der
religion untergeordnet wurden
denn die religion organisierte früher
viele lebensbereiche sind diese
lebensbereiche einmal voneinander
getrennt ist die gefahr dass sie
miteinander in konflikt geraten viel
größer das ist das eine
zudem basiert auch der kapitalismus
selber auf einem gewaltigen widerspruch
einerseits haben wir hoch produktive und
disziplinierte individuen die fähig sind
den eigenen körper zu vergessen und
zwölf stunden zu arbeiten um immer mehr
geld zu verdienen
sie sind also hoch rational produktiv
und diszipliniert andererseits müssen
dieselben individuen auch konsumieren
und sind mit ihren vergnügungen mit dem
bedürfnis nach erholung und
authentizität und mit ihren gefühlen
beschäftigt dieses hin- und
hergerissensein zwischen kontrolle und
sich gehen lassen ist das schwierige los
des modernen individuums und dieser
widerspruch wird vom kapitalismus
gefördert ich höre ihnen so gerne zu
weil sie mich wie selten jemand zwingen
dazu die komplexität auszuhalten sie
sagen dauernd es ist auf der einen seite
so auf der anderen seite so es gibt
einen vorteil es gibt ein nachteil sie
sollten nicht bewerten wir sollten
erstmal nur beschreiben
das hat etwas unglaublich wie soll ich
sagen anspruchsvolles und gleichzeitig
etwas für mich sehr faszinierendes ich
frage mich wenn ich ihnen zuhöre gibt es
in diesem ganzen liebesdingen trotzdem
dinge wo sie sagen würden da es fertig
mit ausgewogenheit mit komplexität
da ist es ein eindeutig so was doch
etwas ganz schief läuft
ich denke falsch ist dass es zwei
forderungen gibt einerseits zu
produzieren und andererseits sich zu
reproduzieren also sich fortzupflanzen
die gesellschaft muss sich fortpflanzen
per definition traditionell haben dass
vor allem die frauen übernommen
sie sind der aufforderung sich
fortpflanzen zu müssen gefolgt der
kapitalismus untergräbt die
fortpflanzung
das müssen wir verstehen und das ist
auch vielen menschen bewusst
wir haben einen konflikt zwischen
produktion und reproduktion sind denn
immer mehr menschen leben allein und
wollen allein leben immer weniger
menschen möchten kinder haben
all dies führt zu einer fortpflanzungs
krise für diese krise sind nicht
frauenbewegungen der feminismus oder die
freiheit verantwortlich sondern die
lebensbedingungen im späten pleistozän
bevölkerung wächst aber nicht in den am
meisten kapitalisierten westlichen
ländern
im gegenteil
in japan ist die reproduktionsrate
gesunken
auch in italien in deutschland und in
den skandinavischen ländern
wir erleben also eine reproduktions
krise was ihre thesen ja auch deutlich
machen ist wie sehr eigentlich eine alte
feministische these stimmt nämlich dass
das private politisch ist das das
liebesleben tief durchdrungen ist von
den wirtschafts verhältnissen von den
politischen verhältnissen
da kann man ja auch die frage stellen
was eigentlich eben mit der
feministischen bewegung eigentlich
passiert ist wenn gleichzeitig das
frauenbild in der pornoindustrie in der
werbeindustrie so sexistisch ist ist die
frauenbewegung die revolution der frauen
auf halbem weg stecken geblieben oder
was ist da genau passiert denke ich
denke es ist folgendes passiert wenn man
fast die ganze infrastruktur der
gesellschaft besitzt die wirtschaft das
militär die kultur
ich spreche von den männern ist es
praktisch unmöglich diese herrschaft
struktur wirklich zu verändern
vergessen wir nicht die eroberungen und
fortschritte der frauen wurden nur
erreicht weil die feministische bewegung
sie erkämpft hat trotzdem ist der
großteil der sozialen infrastruktur in
der politik wie im militär in der
wirtschaft in der religion und dem
rechtssystem in den händen der männer
geblieben auch wenn frauen also eine
emanzipatorische ideologie oder idee
verbreiten wird diese sehr bald von
kräften überrollt die stärker sind
[Musik]
das passierte zb mit der idee der
sexuellen freiheit die feminismus wurde
von der kapitalistischen industrie
gekapert ich würde gerne zum schluss
noch mit ihnen über ein neueres phänomen
sprechen nämlich darüber dass ja auch
männer unter dieser neuen liebes ordnung
leiden
es gibt männer die organisieren sich im
internet als sogenannte in sales in
voluntary selbitz also unfreiwillig
enthaltsame das ist eine gruppe von
männern auf die michel houellebecq
vielleicht als erster aufmerksam
macht hat nämlich männer die in einer
übersexualisierten welt das gefühl haben
zu kurz zu kommen die keine partnerin
finden und vehement aggressiv sexistisch
sich im netz organisieren und fordern
dass die frauen zur monogamie gezwungen
werden damit jedes jedermann eine frau
abbekommt sind auch diese männer eine
folge des kapitalismus
zuerst einmal sind solche auswüchse eine
auswirkung der veränderten patriarchalen
strukturen
wir haben heute verschiedene wenn sie so
wollen herrschaftssysteme die
miteinander konkurrieren
das patriarchat wird von den frauen
bekämpft und während die meisten männer
früher leicht zugang zum weiblichen
körper hatten ist es heute viel
schwieriger seien freiwillig und
wirksame männer reagieren so auf die
geringfügige veränderung der männlichen
privilegien und die erspielten
zugangsmöglichkeiten zum weiblichen
körper der kapitalismus ist zudem dafür
verantwortlich dass sich heterosexuelle
frauen und männer wie auf einem markt
begegnen
er hat heterosexuelle beziehungen
kommerzialisiert märkte werden durch
angebot und nachfrage reguliert nicht
durch familien oder gemeinschaften
welche versuchen haare zu bilden
neoliberalismus trägt der markt dazu bei
dass gewisse menschen weniger
erfolgreich oder gefragt sind da sie
außen vor bleiben
reagieren sie auf diese
kommerzialisierung der sexuellen
beziehungen und den verlust männlicher
privilegien
ein puzzle in das heißt der markt
produziert immer auch seine verlierer
und das ist ein effekt davon wenn
vielleicht zuletzt romantischen liebe
zurück kehren sie die jetzt seit 20
jahren die liebe erforschen was würden
sie sagen warum lohnt sich denn die
suche nach dem einen partner oder
zumindest nach einer stabilen beziehung
wenn die liebe weh tut wenn die liebe
endet zuerst einmal sagte ich nie dass
es sich lohne
ich denke es lohnt sich bedeutungsvolle
beziehungen einzugehen
damit meine ich nicht unbedingt
romantische oder sexuelle beziehungen
wenn ich etwas mit meinen studien
erreichen will dann eine erweiterung
unserer sichtweise und dass wir unser
konzept einer bedeutungsvollen beziehung
erweitern können
sie kann von einer freundschaft
inspiriert seien von der sorge um unsere
mitmenschen oder der liebe für kinder in
gewisser hinsicht gefällt mir die
religiöse sich der liebe die christliche
liebe zu menschen nicht die liebe zu
einem abstrakten gegenüber wie im
christentum sondern die liebe zu einer
konkreten person die nicht unbedingt 16
wandern oder liebespartner sein muss ich
wünsche mir wie ich bereits sagte dass
wir unser vorstellungsvermögen ausweiten
und in unserem leben viel mehr
möglichkeiten
bedeutsame bande zu knüpfen anstatt nur
die romantische liebe zu finden
der romantischen liebe ist ein sehr
enger weg für die menschliche
entwicklung für die entwicklung von
brüderschaft und schwesternschaft ist
das auch der grund warum sie dieses buch
ja widmen ihren familienmitgliedern sie
gefälligst geschwistern mutter und den
kindern
die familie ist heute die einzige nicht
kapitalistischer einrichtung da man sie
sich nicht aussuchen
deshalb ist die familie für mich so
interessant geworden
denn in einer welt in der sie in
jeglicher hinsicht bestimmen wer sie
sind auch was ihren körper ihre
sexualität ihren haarschnitt ihre es
vorlieben usw betrifft ist die familie
das einzige das sie nicht wählen
sie ist daher ein ort wo man unglaublich
viel lernt und wachsen kann
denn in der familie muss man schlichtweg
mit dem leben was einem gegeben worden
ist
das finde ich interessant
deshalb nehme ich die familie einen
unmodernen aus sie ist wenn sie so
wollen das einzige überbleibsel der
traditionellen gesellschaft in unserem
modernen gesellschaft ganz herzlich dass
wir uns hier in berlin treffen könnten
danke sehr
nächste woche werden die schweizer
vielen preise verliehen
wer sich chancen ausrechnen darf und ob
die nominationen gerechtfertigt sind das
diskutiert jetzt gleich monika scherer
mit ihren gästen
danke für ihr interesse eine gute woche
und bis bald
[Musik]